[Music]
my name is Andrew toy I'm a product
management director within the Android
and chrome team and today I'm gonna talk
to you about Google and Google basically
how do we manage devices and security
and secure access within Google itself
so when I'm talking about Google I mean
Google as in Googlers our own employees
access to our own data our own code if
you were to come and work at Google how
do you get a device
and things like that we're not talking
about you necessarily our products that
we do use our own products as part of
this so our own IT department our own IT
sector department quick poll on a people
don't really love this but just put your
up your hands if you work in IT a lot of
IT folks and maybe a subset of that but
if you're in the security part like CSO
office or suck-ups or anything like that
okay
so handle security people so going there
and one last hands up hands up if you
your company and you're responsible for
working with your own MDM or EMM or uem
solutions from the regard okay cool
thank you very much that just helps me
calibrate a little bit what we're
talking about today
so why device management matters since a
lot of you are from an IT audience you
guys understand why device management
matters right I work a lot of our own
core banish'd apartment and office
obviously we need control we need access
we can't just let data flow willy-nilly
we need to know where our data is being
actors from how it's being accessed it's
about security it's about management's
about control today everything I talk
about is our general principles of how
we manage our endpoints so yes I come
from a sort of phone and tablet side but
we're including laptops in there because
what we're seeing is that while laptops
and desktops have been around for much
longer and they've always been ways to
update and fix them you know with
patching and with things like bigfix and
image and images and flashing what we're
seeing is that the modern way of doing
management which is through a set of
management api's through strict data
separations through security by default
through our rigorous app stores for app
deployment that's the way we see
endpoint management going across all
endpoints all the way through
certainly mobile and tablets and through
lap
tops of desktops but even all the way
through to a IOT and Internet of Things
so this isn't the IOT talk I also cover
that I'm happy to answer questions about
that if folks happen so why do we really
need this well a lot of things have
changed in the last few years like since
the upcoming advent of mobile a lot of
groups have sprung up a lot of new
technologies a lot of new vendors have
come to us and said hey you know we do
device management and this is how you go
a lot of you your EMM or MDM will be
coming to you and saying well I used to
do just mobile but I want to do your
laptop so I want to do all your
endpoints as we move to a um unified
endpoint management world so all this
won't be new to you folks when we're
trying to manage a lot of this
complexity and say how do we have a
principle that overrides and runs
through all of our various endpoints so
we're not solving things in an
individual way and something I always
said is that Mobile is not its own thing
mobile was its own thing for the last
few years we have mobile groups billing
up we have mobile application developers
mobile device management vendors but
really mobile is kind of like what
internet was in the early 2000s right in
the early 2008 90s the internet was very
new a lot of companies said well we need
an internet division and an internet
group and I'm gonna have an internet
part of my company an internet set of
people who work on that stuff but what
happened was everything is internet
right right Internet is interwoven into
the fabric of all of our companies and
that's the same thing about mobile
Mobile is more just about the
proliferation of devices the
proliferation of access the
proliferation of networks onto cellular
networks right which breaks down the old
models of how we used to do things in IT
so one of the reasons I give this talk
and you know I was introducing myself as
a product director I ran android for
work which is part of the initiative to
bring Android into the enterprise but I
also ran mobile application security and
development at Morgan Stanley for over
five years so I sat on both sides of
this and so I I think very carefully
about what it's like to be within an
organization and trying to manage this
complexity and saying what I would do if
I were you folks
in the modern world so how do i do
things like google and why is it a
little bit different first of all we
definitely have an open culture and this
open culture means that we tend to lean
towards failing open that means that we
don't have this idea of okay well you
know I have my walls I have my buildings
I have my intranet I'm gonna go ahead
and lock into that and manage everything
through those Gardens um are people
familiar have who here is familiar with
our beyond Corp initiative and has read
some of those papers okay great everyone
I would recommend for everybody is that
you familiarize yourself beyond Corp Co
RP is what you'll want to Google look
around for materials I think we've a
link at the end of the deck for it as
well but yuan Corp is something that
would absolutely familiarize yourself
with if I was working in IT today which
is Google's VP endless intranet list way
of approaching how we deploy
applications yes we are cloud centric
yes we are cloud native we have a ton of
advantages but the principles apply to
every company which is really the idea
of being secure and safe and managed
because you're on your intranet those
days are rapidly going behind right
that's an old model if it's reaching the
end of its life time is what we believe
so here at Google we don't we actually
do have an intranet we have Google - a
for example for our Wi-Fi which is an
intranet and we have Google guests but I
will say that on my laptop I can't
remember the last time I needed to be on
my internet to access anything special
right I can be on oftentimes if I'm like
oh I got a little bit of a problem on
Google eh I'll just jump over to Google
guests and keep it right on working
I don't refire up a VPN and I don't do
anything I just keep on going right I
can bring my laptop from the internet
pick it up take it home there's no once
again no VPN nothing all the security is
done through HTTP through certs I'll
talk more about that in a minute
but the idea is that's the experience
we're trying to give to Googlers is not
well where am i and what network am i on
and how do I access things we try to
make all that go away so people could
just get their work done immediately so
we fail to this idea of really good user
experiences and are willing to really
push the boundaries of moving
you know traditional comfort zones of IT
to make sure that when people are able
to work in this way of course Security's
paramount to us but we but we are up for
doing the extra engineering we need to
make sure we have security and we have
access so just talking about that we're
very aware right we're Google we have
Gmail we we are you know when people
look at like how people are getting
hacked and stuff about phishing we take
security extremely extremely extremely
seriously this is a theme of next and
hopefully all of you guys are getting it
we are very aware that people that
professionals are being targeted you
know I come from Morgan Stanley I know
they from financial services very
high-value targets for phishing for
social engineering for people trying to
get in with malware very aware of all of
these targets so security throughout
this talk is absolutely paramount to
everything that we do right we have a
group internally for analysts for
detection for response for prevention on
all of our endpoints so when I tell you
something like hey we don't need to have
an intranet it's not because we're just
taking it through our security to wind
it's because we have a new way of
approaching these problems and by the
way I'll have room for questions at the
end what you'll be to ask them but if
you wanted to stick up your hand at any
point I'm happy to take questions
throughout the presentation so this is
ours you might have heard him speak
again
Orr's runs our technical infrastructure
team and he also owns the IT and
internal corporate engineering
department which we refer to as Corp
edge and we I think often say this and
when I worked in an IT like we would say
this all the time but I want to refocus
everyone in the room because I think
this is something we want to keep in
front of our minds IT and security is an
enabler right it's not it should not be
something that restricts what you can do
security is what enables you to do stuff
right so in your personal lives when you
pay with something with your credit card
you are aware that this feels like a
generally secure way to pay right like
even though there is credit card fraud
out there you're dealing with fraud
unlike a day to day basis I like oh my
god I can't pay at this restaurant
because they might steal my credit card
number hopefully you're not right and
because you have that sense of security
and because of all that work has gone
into the security of
mints you feel very comfortable using
your credit card in a lot of different
scenarios right so that's the kind of
feeling you want to have as you work
through and as you you just want to have
is that they know they're secure so they
get this freedom and this liberation to
actually do more to often security ends
up just being a gate or a blocker no
offense to the security people in the
room but oftentimes you know when we
talk to customers we talk to the IT side
they say oh well you know we'll have to
get this through our security department
and what we try to say is let's try and
get to a relationship where security and
IT are collaborating to say how do we
explore the art of the possible
while still keeping it absolutely secure
so these are kind of three dimensions of
what we really feel on the one hand the
security IT security information
security you may have the same
department who does both that's both of
those things it might be a different
department who does InfoSec from sec ops
definitely there's usability and I
talked about that I think we all
intuitively know what usability is and
there's also privacy and this is a
really important part of the day of the
puzzle as well because if you share all
of your information all of the time and
you actually surrender all of your
privacy as an individual it actually
makes the security person that's job a
lot easier just to be honest right but
that's not necessarily what employees
want to do and that's something we need
to take into account as well right
even though you know we all have the big
terms of services that can flash up and
say you have no expectation of privacy
we can access all your information you
know while you're on net yes of course
the company can do all those things the
company necessarily shouldn't
necessarily do all those things unless
it really has to so these are the three
pillars that we think about security
usability and privacy and we don't want
we recognize that you know it's always a
little bit of a push and a pull in each
direction part of the art and the
science here is finding a way to find
the right blend of all those things so
that you could have a wonderful access
strategy internally whether you're
excited about
so this is part of like what we were
gonna go here like um I work on mobile
in these sort of pure blackberry days
right like the days when it was like
well that's it you know blackberry did a
great job solving this problem we're
gonna deploy but a blackberries it's
gonna be blackberry fruit through and
through we're gonna run the best server
we're gonna just give up blackberries
all good right and that was on the one
hand liberating because this was a
mobile strategy for the first time that
IT could take and say well we agree this
is secure this is great
let's deploy it let's get mobile access
to all of these the employees who've
never had it on the other hand it was
semi constraining right because what
actually was happening was all this
traffic was right if he was being
deferred to effectively one company rim
right researcher motion who makes
blackberry and so when you do that
basically you're outsourcing your
strategy to a vendor in that case you're
like my strategy is blackberry which is
kind of a strategy but actually what
you're saying is my strategy is
blackberry strategy and they go hand in
hand I know what what happened was is
that great yes to everything blackberry
no to everything else and that was fine
because blackberry really was a very
good device when the iPhone came around
I kind of blew up that model a lot right
you couldn't really go to the business
stakeholders and say oh well you know
what it just blackberry blackberry some
people still can I know if customers who
are still in that world even today right
but most companies have not moved to a
world with they're like well listen this
is not the way we can run our strategy
anymore we have to be able to at least
you iOS and a lot of companies just say
you know what for B why would even where
support iOS and flavors of Android this
is how we want to run our strategy so
really you need to embrace mobility and
embrace access and have feel comfortable
that you are covered in all regards and
not just say this is my strategy is to
restricted devices and that's it because
even if you can find a good middle
ground today and say you know what it's
not just blackberries blackberry and
iPhone technology keeps on rolling
forward right they'll sue me another
killer device another killer platform
another way we're approaching it how are
you gonna do irt sensors how are you
going to Duke ml when people want to
access data from their assistant units
which are sitting in their Google home
technology's pushing and pushing and
pushing and pushing us to be able to
have more access for our company in more
esoteric places all the time I would not
say that the answer is not to just sort
of say well it's this then it's this
Plus this there's this Plus this was
this you want to strategy that embraces
and allows you to approach everything at
once so how we how do we think about
access control we break everything down
and we say well first of all let's make
sure we have a really good idea of how
we think of our people this is gonna be
your identity strategy your your iam
strategy devices which is endpoints at
the state of those endpoints and how
they're managed and what data is going
to those endpoints and this is the one
that people often overlook even though
it's the most important probably should
be the most obvious one applications how
do we think of and categorize our
various applications so we can decide
what's appropriate to access at any
given time and we're so on device
management we actually centralized all
these concepts so that we are able to
control and have knobs to I say this is
what can be accessed from where on which
data device so again we we move away
from the monolithic concept of on net of
net on VPN off VPN on mobile did too
many too many of those variables makes
it impossible to solve the equation what
we instead said is let's identify
general security and access postures
tiers we call a tiered access that was
slightly coming up how do we generalize
it into those categories how do we know
which applications go into which
category and then let's just define in
any given moment in time which state a
given endpoint and user combination is
in and are they in a good enough state
that we're willing to act to give access
to a given application it's actually
pretty simple when I describe it that
way but that's just a general mantra
that we know that we that we go through
so on the people level we want to make
sure that a given identity has access to
the right application so this is fairly
simple stuff but but you're gonna make
sure that
you actually have this to deploy
properly in your environment which is
maybe you're in HR and so you should
differ be able to say okay well I should
be able to see the actual employee
records of a whole bunch of different
people I should be to go in and log into
that application and see those employee
records okay fantastic
maybe you should only see it for your
department maybe you shouldn't see it
for the entire organization maybe you're
not in HR you shouldn't be able to see
those records unless you're the manager
of those people all most of your company
should have these concepts already in
place I'm just making sure that we have
it for the sake of completeness but for
HR you might have those in place but you
might not have those in other
applications right the idea is for HR
you're like well that makes total sense
we should do it for payroll well yeah
I'm gonna do it there that makes total
sense
right but you got to go for your
population of applications and make sure
that for each application you have an
idea of who should be able access it and
when on the devices standpoint so we did
all that for our internal applications
on the devices standpoint here at Google
just because people ask these questions
but we support a variety of different
devices that we support Android and on
Android we support our pixel devices at
any Nexus device at the highest tier of
access we also support Chrome OS at the
highest tier of access and we support
Mac OS and Windows at our highest serial
access so we actually support an entire
population when a Googler comes in you
might think that every Googler gets an
Android device but you'll see that a lot
of Google's are actually carrying around
iOS devices and I'll explain what their
experience is like versus an Android
device you'll see a lot of Googlers
carrying Mac devices fewer carrying
Windows but then they have those as well
lots of us carry chrome actually it's a
completely individual decision by every
Googler which device they want to get
you can just go to the internal portal
and say this is the device I want if you
want when you're refresh your memory
refresh cycle is up you can say you know
what I have been been on Mac OS I want
to go to Chrome OS for a while and you
can absolutely you can absolutely do
that all of these platforms are
supported at the highest here we have
the most amount of trust in these
particular platforms from an application
standpoint we use a variety of
applications obviously we are a G suite
customer a very very big G's V customer
and we have
all those applications and it we have
and this kind of interesting I don't we
do not have generically named app
applications like that they probably do
have names on the on the other side but
we have the usual third-party
applications which we also have access
to and we and we build across all those
using our Google identity so I don't
know what people are on G suite but if
you're on G suite you'll know that you
can Center your entire identity on that
Google identity when you log into
various cloud services you could say log
in with your Google identity we
completely centralized around that and
what that allows us to tax on a mice
which applications we can get access to
at any given time so how do we bring
these concepts together and sort of set
the access so I mentioned this to this
before and this is like a really key
point right tiered access more this is
one of those areas where having more
granular settings actually allows you to
have much more flexibility and actually
how you grant access to certain things
so I've often had a conversation with
c-level folks for very big corporations
who just sort of say to me Android yes
or no you know secure or not secure
right should I allow access or not allow
access and we're like you know I
although say BYOD yes or no secure or
not secure should I allow access or not
allow access and it's kind of awkward
question to answer right because it
shouldn't be this binary secure or not
secure right like there's what are the
exit and I'm the Android guy right it's
like I said listen I think be why are
you secure and I can show you how to
make it secure like got it boom secure
and I'm like wait hold on before you
take the secure box I will say that I
personally would be extremely
uncomfortable if you're military
generals are carrying around nuclear
codes on their BYOD phone right really
uncomfortable I don't think you should
give out nuclear codes to PYD devices
then they're like got it insecure and
I'm like okay no no all right
like like please don't please don't
think about it in this way right it's
just not it can't be these two boxes
because it depends on what kind of data
you're carrying right so while most
companies hopefully do not
nuclear codes there are that there are
those crown jewel pieces of data that
you might want to have so it would be
cool even though you treat be worthy as
secure it would be not unreasonable for
you to give out dedicated corporate
tablets to your board so that for board
of director meetings you can give the
most privileged information to the board
of directors without having to worry
about an solve a bunch of BYOD concerns
it just means you have to have a nuanced
granular strategy to add an approach and
so we do tiered access and we did where
the tiered access works is that we
classify the internal services like I
said that means that we declare what's
in the crown jewel category the nuclear
codes we categorize what yeah you know
what we probably need to know that
you're a Googler and we need to know
that you did in general that you're in
good standing and all those kinds of
things and once we have that that's good
enough and we also we're just fine with
this like just just access the data and
as totally and it totally makes sense so
we have also in order for this to work
we have to know what state your devices
are in we have to know to help us do
security and we also and this is implied
by let's talk about it specifically here
need to centralized access so while we
don't have the VPN we do have something
and beyond corporates that get talked
about exactly what we do here we do
centralize all the access to our
services so I'm going to skip over this
for now I took what talk about the
centralization in the centralization we
have access control engines and Trust at
first that's it between the endpoints
and access to all of our applications
now remember we are cloud native is we
completed MIT that this is our one of
our biggest strengths is that the since
everything sits at the cloud there's a
limited number of protocols in fact
almost everything flows over HTTP and
HTTPS right so we're able to limit
access to our services by having a
limited number of protocols and limits
and reports and all kind of good stuff
so while we don't have a traditional
internet extranet service what we've
done is move that concept into the
application layer so our actual HTTP and
M proxies and our actual servers are
able to be aware of the state of a
vice before granting that access over to
a particular service on the back end and
the services are themselves also aware
of the endpoint accessing them so we're
not saying you know we have to issue you
a private IP in order for this to
actually work it's not a network level
concept this is what and the same exact
proxies are used to access services no
matter which network I'm on the only
thing that changes is the level of trust
changes because we're able to analyze
when I want to Starbucks Network yes
that is a different security posture
than when I'm on my home network which
is a different security posture than
what I'm on my intranet that is
definitely true but we don't use a on
net off net model to try and define the
access model from that point so we do
have this if you look at we actually
launched a publicly available version of
this which is called our gateway product
which was launching here at next it's
coming into beta a trusted tester and
it's something where we make this proxy
technology available to two other
customers combined with the actual proxy
here the gatekeeper what we actually use
is a trust engine an access control
engine which is saying all right so I
have everything funneled through now
it's all going through my proxies it's
it protected my services I know how
secure my service is so what do I want
to do in terms of actually granting
access or not granting access and in
this case here are a few examples of
what we do we actually are always
collecting data and we collect this data
using our our own internal EMM so we
actually use the GCM have to do it plus
some tools that we developed on scripts
we developed so this is collecting logs
endpoint status reporting on what's
going on on the endpoint reporting what
applications are on the endpoint seeing
whether we think there's any known
malware there lots and lots and lots of
data which is being collected from our
endpoints at all times and actually
saying okay what is the level of trust
we put on this particular device and
therefore on in real time we could
adjust the security posturing all of
those particular devices so if today we
suddenly find out hey you know what
there's a newly discovered class of
malware running on our Windows laptops
for example we didn't know about it
yesterday we'd know what about it today
we can actually instead of saying well
we will go and say let's go and scan and
let
flash and remove malware and make sure
we do that in the fleet but to make sure
we have immediate protection we can say
let's change the trust engine to say
that if we know that this particular
application is installed on a Windows
machine no longer Act allow access from
that Windows machine to our most secure
technology right so therefore that
because that's actually in our cloud and
on the endpoint who determine the access
we are able to move them down and that
that user can probably still get email
they can still do their regular work but
they might not be able to access you
know the crown jewels at that point
until they're remediated and then once
they're remediated they can get access
again to everything else so we collect
all of this data and we're able to
crunch it we use machine learning we use
our we have a security analyst team we
have a lot of different teams you can
imagine what we're doing it there too
and to make sure that everything is
working so tiers of access let's let's
sort of get down to some brass tacks
there's actually us another tier here
could untrusted but we're getting rid of
that so this minimally trusted mostly
trusted and fully trusted right very
easy language language to use you can
map this you can take something
minimally trusted is basic access and
what we mean by that is stuff where
you're like ok you know you need to do
your job and to be really honest if a
third if someone who's not a Googler
looked at this stuff
it's not really the end of the world
right so but it you know it's not just
the most basic stuff but it's just stuff
where we don't we don't really try and
care too much definitely stuff like our
bus schedules would be in there right
our menu and cafeteria access is in
there that that's in there but
interestingly and and a lot of customers
find this interesting
we actually put email in that category
as well because we find email to be as
extension to the way that I did for
someone to actually get their job done
and so we wanted to be able to get their
job done in a lot of different places so
emails Docs sheets and slides are
actually all in the minimally trusted
category so if you bring in BYOD today
to Google you can bring in any BYOD to
phone and you can get your email on that
phone right I know a lot of you probably
have like an approach but you can't do
that you can't do that we trust that we
trusted
suite of applications we trust G suite
at the intent if the inherent app
security built into the cloud to keep
all of that stuff safe
mostly trusted is normal access and what
we mean and what we mean by that is okay
we're gonna have a strongly a stronger
position around exactly what your
identity is we're gonna have a better
idea about the state your devices in and
most you should get access to most
applications to get your job done if
you're sitting in mostly mostly trust it
you shouldn't have to go to all the way
to fully trust it in order to get your
job done because I know people are
already thinking oh okay well that must
mean that fully trusted is the best tier
we must put everything into fully
trusted and then just who I'm done but
if you do that once again you don't
really have a strategy right what you
once again have the binary strategy
where you're either fully or you're not
fully and if you're not fully then
you're just a straight-up second-class
citizen that's not our approach our
approach is if we're doing a good job
you should be able to do the vast
majority of job day-to-day sitting in a
mostly in a mostly trusted tier and you
should be to do most of your job sitting
in a minimally trusted a good amount of
job in the millimetres of tier and but
certain things you might have to go to
to fully trust it to fully trust it on
so as an example when I go home I need
to have a two-factor authentication to
get into mostly trusted right but I can
take my move my two-factor
authentication and I can use it with my
home computer that's my computer that I
own and so it's not image it's not
flashed it's not anything like that um
it also doesn't give up a lot of logs or
anything back to Google I can put my
two-factor token in I can get
intermittent at the internet middle
mostly trusted state and I can do the
vast majority of my job on that
particular on that particular computer
when I work from home so again very
simple examples cafe menu probably
totally fine to be that lower tier
there's not a lot you're gonna do with
that right but you know I'm not gonna be
able to go and check my my even my own
payroll status from that from a
particular device and I certainly aren't
gonna be I'm looking here to go and
check in code download code certainly
don't push the production machines
again that middle tier where like I'm
able to do sort of most of my job I
remember I'm not an engineer so when I
say most of my job I don't need to code
for a living it's a sibling product but
uh tender controls there and we have
applications I sit by category so now I
can access more private more secure
information where really it being me is
important remember now I requires to
factor in order to get in there
so okay wonderful sure to live access
tokens shorter lived shorter lives
identity tokens requires two-factor to
get in there but now if you do all those
things you're able to go in and check
payroll and do an I can I can approve
expense reports and those kind of things
in that category and finally the last
here again based on your business all
these things will apply for us our crown
jewels we're Google our crown jewels are
is our code and our cloud in our
production base right so we do require
you to be on a fully trusted fully
interrogated machine it ordered to be to
access that data to do those things here
at here at Google
so how I actually doing this on laptops
I refer to mobile a little bit this is
kinda for the world a lot of people are
sitting in right now and we do this as
well right like we do this for older OSS
we have the virus we have antivirus we
have our own images for Mac OS we've our
own images for for Windows we're also
custody upgrading those we're doing to
go into Patch Tuesday stuff for Windows
we issued a patches we we do everything
that your companies are probably doing
to make sure that that fleet stays up to
date if you're if you're not doing those
things you should probably be doing
those things on any of your on any of
your operating systems so we do go
through this but we we don't love this
world right we don't think this is a
modern way for people living and it
feels constraining it feels like busy
work that needs to be done just for the
sake of security not really enabling and
anything good so what we did is for both
chrome and Android and here I will Duke
it give the example using Chrome OS
Chrome OS is actually fully trusted out
of the box
Windows is not fully trusted out of the
box right I cannot go and get a
off-the-shelf Windows laptop bring it in
and say yeah yeah yeah this is a Google
laptop and then bring in two fully
trusted it has to run our windows image
my
os has to run our Mac image Chrome OS
does not run a special Google image it
uses the consumer image right this is
what I'm giving this example out of the
box
same thing for Android do not have its
own image for Android runs the consumer
image ya can get into fully trusted it
can get into that highest tier security
for us right again
I'm just reiterate for to set your
intuition Windows laptop at home using
it at home great you can get into you
can get into minimally for sure maybe
even two mostly but they get into get
into fully you're gonna always have to
have an image running from Google in
this particular case chrome that's not
the case and that's because chrome and
Android and iOS right like are running
in a more modern way of doing operating
systems and chrome in this case has
verified boot TPMS encryption out of the
box and boxing of the actual processes
and all IR all these things so very
verified boot for example we feel
comfortable because we know that the
chrome image is always signed it has
tamper protection it has tamper
resistance and so we know it is always
using a google signed from the
manufacturer firmware image on that
particular device and we have the same
thing on Android now as well so you
might not know this but on Android if
someone was to flash a custom rom etc
you can absolutely detect that through
your EMM and and either prevent it or
you can say well if someone's access it
has a custom ROM no fully trusted access
which is what we do at Google right so
you have to be using the manufacturer
Rama that matter than manufacturer OS we
leverage the TPM on Chrome OS for
storing secure keys so if we're gonna
give a long-lasting identity token so
this is something we try and do and
fully trust it is you don't want to be
logging in over and over and over and
over again for security purposes so we
need a way to give long lasting identity
and long lasting auth tokens and an
identity tokens out to these particular
devices so by using the TPM as the root
of trust were able to actually do that
of higher confidence rather than having
really important tokens sitting in
somewhere on the on the on disk where
they can be extracted and used by an
attacker right so that's an important
thing is to have a appropriate route of
trust processor stance and boxing a
process processes
sandboxing so inherently everything's
run its own processed those processes
are protected against each other so if
you have a piece of malware it's very
difficult for it to attack another
process it's difficult for it to extract
data from another directory all of this
is built again again from the ground up
by default in modern operating systems
there might be the point there that some
of you may not understand which is we
actually also have the Play Store and
Android applications now running on
Chrome OS and that is also running in a
separate process which is isolated from
the main kernel so that we can actually
make sure that we have high amounts of
security from any Android app can be
downloaded does not interfere of any of
the security on the Chrome OS site and
of course updates right and this is just
as you know a really painful thing a lot
of investment going into here but on
Chrome OS zero zero percent IT is effort
is spent in to managing updates managing
patches managing like like figuring out
what's going to all those things we use
the exact same over-the-air every six
week automatic update process that that
a regular chrome OS consumer user would
use everything is baked into that cycle
we can we don't here but just speaking
for how you can manage Chrome OS it has
a full set of EMM controls that you can
use with it you can't delay those
updates cuz sometimes you want to do
verification checking and testing and
stuff like that but because of the
nature of Chrome OS because everything
is really running through the browser
because of we're rich once again cloud
native our need to actually go and say
oh let me test all my applications is
almost zero because we don't have that
legacy application burden that we do on
other platforms so the benefits of this
approach is that it's greatly simplified
for IT we know that we're secure by
default so we're able to grant that high
tier of access to to to Chrome OS to
Android just out of the box right and it
has a wonderful employee experience cuz
you can just get up and running and
don't have to worry about anything so
I'll give you an example of what I did
yesterday
you might have noticed that we're
presenting from a lot of Chrome OS
devices here at next but what happened
was is I needed to present from my
laptop at this presentation but a
different one as somewhere else and so
what actually happened was I was like
well I have it
set up on my laptop and I could get
access to it I'm here and it's a
privileged document I want to present a
pretty privileged site that I needed to
get to so instead of saying well how do
I unplug this laptop and plug everything
in and get it all working on the screen
everything like that
all I had to do was go to that device
and I just said login as a new user I've
never logged into this device before
never right I said long as a new user
login as Andrew it's already a privilege
device I put in my security key I logged
in I got all access to everything
immediately on my own from my own drive
and my own talks and everything pulled
up at the site I needed pull up the site
great did my presentation then locked
out said destroy the session and
everything is removed in the Chrome
device right nothing completely secure
but I can use any Chrome device in the
Google fleet and within I would guy I'm
just saying within a minute I had that
absolutely set up to be me just the way
I wanted with all of my access all my
privileges everything I need so that's
what we mean by a hands employee
experience we don't force people to use
Chrome it's a choice that people can
make they can get a Mac they can get a
Windows Device but there's some nice
advantages of using Chrome so this is
another example chrome grab and go this
is what I just said but in the form of
sometimes I leave my laptop at home
because I'm absent-minded and this
happens actually quite a lot so as long
as I carry my security key what I can do
is we just have these massive banks of
Chromebooks that just sit in every
building and if you forget your laptop
you can just go grab a generic one no IT
interference but you're gonna talk to IT
you don't even file ticket you just grab
it they're all getting power right there
you stick in your security security key
you set it up for yourself just the way
I said use login basically if your
credential you use it all day and
because I'm a chrome OS user it feels
exactly the same as using my own laptop
right I use it for today at the end of
it when I'm done with it I just stick it
back in there and I just put the power
back in and the Pantages ok great thanks
for returning your Chromebook and I go
home that's it right so it's completely
self-service it's completely secure I
mean we didn't make it secure it's
literally just the same as my own laptop
the only reason I have my own laptop is
because I just like the idea of
ownership I guess but really from a from
actually
my job double standpoint there's no
difference literally no difference
between me using my own laptop and using
one of these loners other than the fact
I like the idea that I own my own I have
my own laptop so how do you take this
we're playing room for questions at the
end I can take it take this anywhere
anywhere you want so how do we actually
plug this in building a phased approach
so you definitely want to start slowly
and start looking you don't just
revolutionize and change your entire
thing and say we're going to be on Corp
all at once but you want to say how do
you build the best experience for your
users how do you make sure that you've
identified the users who need access to
things gone through your applications
texana mize your applications make sure
you know what people are accessing and
get at all that stuff under control you
want to have a dedicated team working on
your devices I mean I was guessing most
of you probably do because you're in
this session you're probably part of
this team but you do want have people
who are thinking about this every day
because if they're not you don't once
again you're not gonna have a strategy
she was gonna have tactics right so you
want to have a strategy for your
organization that's right for you we
think that the concepts I've talked
about today again they're high-level but
they apply to 95% of companies but that
doesn't mean you can just take him and
immediately do them you do need to make
sure you do the work that to adapt them
to your own company's needs so you need
a team who's working on that so in this
particular case you do need to make sure
that your security model also transcends
everything again where we are is not
somewhere you can get to in one step we
were cloud native from the very start
with a shared security model from the
very start with a shared identity model
we have a lot of advantages here at
Google we recognize this but you want to
get to the point where your security
team and your IT team are in the same
page in terms of all this kind of stuff
and how what's gonna be necessary for a
given application on any given than any
given endpoint and within Google things
debate rages because we have the right
tool set with the tiered access but
there's huge debate and huge threads
which say you know what is it safe to
give this exact application access now
it's always been in fully but maybe now
we can get away with it mostly because
we have a new signal from mostly devices
that allow us to feel more confident and
then you know security and IT will
debate and talk and collaborate for
months and then we're like you know what
let's
give it a try and we'll move its access
and we'll give it to it on a different
team we'll try so this is this is a live
strategy right there's my talk about
today is more of a framework for how you
get there but putting the right service
in the right tier is really important
because again once again otherwise the
temptation is just put it all and fully
don't trust anything else and you've
gone back to the binary days and you're
not gonna get any benefit from this
strategy here you what you'll be able to
do because you do this is once again
deploy service is much more quickly than
you've been able to before when you're
worried about malware and all these
kinds of things you actually greatly
reduces and I gave that example before
for a reason it's actually very
confidence boosting to know that if you
see any threat no matter what the threat
is you can make adjustments in your
cloud policy to make sure that your
surface area for attack is greatly
reduced without having to worry about
your endpoint fleet because you always
have that issue where you're like well
what percentage of Eisley is patched
what percentage is running this malware
can we reduce that well this person is
traveling so we kind of just isn't what
you want to do is take wait all those
things are just facts of life but what
you can actually do is we can deploy the
services and put the security and
control in the cloud and by doing that
we don't have to worry so much about the
actual end state posture because we know
we're still protected yes that
individual user might lose some access
to some services for a while but that's
appropriate and generally unavoidable
you definitely have to make good
hardware choices so just Blake like I
said before this is not about BYOD safer
no and people have come to me because
I'm Android guy they're like Samsung
safer know how safe compared to LG and
I'm like listen like there's this
information that can be shared amongst
all these various things and I'll tell
you exactly where you were here is I
mean that we could talk about exactly
where we've ranked various devices here
at Google but what we say is there's a
role for every device in your actual
when you have to here at access there's
a role for probably pretty much every
device because even they're very low
levels of of of trust you can give
access to some services it shouldn't be
all or nothing and the more services you
can get comfortable with it that basic
tier I think the better off you're going
to be but still for there's higher tier
stuff you want to make the right
hardware choices about which platforms
you support so
ultimately this is all moving towards
tear tear teared right like make me give
yourself and arm yourself with this
framework and the tools you need so your
job is just making really clever
insightful decisions about where your
risk profile is and where you're
comfortable taking the risk not with
what I see all the time is people just
be constrained by that example I gave
before right BYOD safe or not safe if
you're even thinking about it in those
terms it means you've tied your own
hands in your ability to solve this
problem and you will be forced to deploy
an imperfect solution to the problem
just by definition you just don't have
the tools you need to actually solve it
right it's a hard enough question when
you have the tools you need right
because we again we debate all the time
and what should be on the byv device
which is not but if you just have one
big lever for access and not access
you've already crippled yourself in this
in this standpoint so there's a lot of
nuance a bit behind behind all of this
and I don't want to necessarily say this
is a one-stop shop this is Ricky no a
one-hour session that you're all hearing
about this and this is years of thought
that we put into it we published white
papers that you can read about it you
could you can talk to your cloud reps to
hear more about how we do it here at
Google we have whole things where our IT
department is able to share our
learnings etc this is not just a boom
we've sold it easy by this product
you're all done that's not what I'm here
to tell you what I'm here to tell you is
it is relatively straightforward though
to go and talk about you within your
company to say what's our overarching
strategy on two end point access do we
have the strategy we need to take us
forward for the next few years where
device profession is just going to be
off the charts right off the charts now
is the time to be ready for all the
various devices and access points that
you're gonna have coming forward as
everything moves into the cloud and as
we just proliferate devices to every
single part of the workplace and I have
a whole connecting workspaces discussion
that I talk did I give which is not
today but where I talk about where we
see the proliferation of devices going
and coming from so for you it is it
there's a few links here I apologize for
the relatively difficult things to type
in but uh but you can take a look
definitely Google around look at beyond
Corp lucid are looking at some of our
best practices practice advisories read
more about
access and these are areas that you can
do to familiarize yourself more further
reading further homework to see how you
adapt this to your own organization and
we as Google are obviously here to help
you as well because I think I will say
that um there's two things when I joined
Google that really blew my mind I'm like
Google just does so much better you know
I've been here for three years now right
but and I've been the enterprise
mobility and security forever but
there's two products which honestly as
Angie I'm like blew my mind on how good
they are here at Google where I'm like
every company needs to be like this one
was video conferencing there's nothing
to do with this talk but I'm just giving
you one of them video conferencing is
really good at Google like every single
every single meeting has video
conferencing every single meeting is
just good just you know if you come in
viral VC totally part of the culture
takes like one like three seconds to set
up a video conference even ad-hoc
one-on-ones of like hey you wanna meet
sure let's meet let's do a VC takes me
three seconds to set that up right
amazingly good at Google like blows my
mind and the second area is the approach
to endpoint security and access I've
never seen such a focus on security
because it's Google and also such a
focus on giving us much access all the
time to our employees and saying they're
more more how can we step up our
security story so we can give more to
people on lower tiers of access while
still remaining protected that is just
built into the culture and what that
mean is a Googler is if you feel like
you can just focus on getting your job
done right never does my devices and
access really feel like it's getting in
my way it just feels like I'm always
able to just get stuff done get stuff
done which is which is really my job I
really honestly not just like work here
feel like there's a really tremendous
things that Google has done very very
well
[Music]